Dr. Falconis selected three hardcover copies
of “Steve Jobs” by Walter Isaacson for
testing with the Clockworks.
The first copy was placed on the setting 1:1.
The output produced was a hardcover copy of
“Bill Gates” by Walter Isaacson.
Upon investigation, the book was revealed
to be an in-depth biography of Microsoft founder
Bill Gates.
The next book copy was placed in the machinery
on the setting “Fine.”
It produced a DVD that depicted Steve Jobs
narrating his biography in the style of an
audiobook.
The final copy was placed on the setting “Very
Fine.”
The output was a metallic cube with a single
button.
When the button was pressed, the cube projected
a holographic image of Steve Jobs, which displayed
sapience and an ability to answer various
questions about Jobs’ life and Apple Computers.